so here's an example okay here's a great
example of people propagating
information that just is not true
and then reversing themselves
willy-nilly so for months we heard that
if you open schools it was a disaster
mostly we heard that from a media that
was convinced that trump had to be wrong
about everything
because trump was out there saying you
need to open the schools this is silly
it's bad
it's hurting kids and teachers unions
were saying no no we need to keep the
schools closed
and for months the media were like you
know what trump's the worst man let's
keep those schools close we don't know
how dangerous it's going to be
it could kill little kids we don't know
doesn't matter the stats show that
little kids are not dying of this
it still could kill little kids right
it's deeply deeply dangerous
and then people take that to heart and
this leads to footage like this footage
this is from oregon of a teacher
stopping an anti-lockdown protester to
scream and shout like a crazy person
because she is very upset that people
are protesting against lockdowns
and she's talking about how her parents
family or her kids families are dying of
covid
and how she's at risk here's a little
bit of that footage
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
okay that sort of hysteria i mean that
is hysteria there's no other way to put
it that sort of hysteria is utterly
unjustified
but it's been pushed by t-shirts unions
and by the media
the chicago's teachers union over the
weekend tweeted out it's got 20 000
28 000 members they tweeted out quote
the push to reopen schools
is rooted in sexism racism and misogyny
sexism racism and misogyny right this
has been the narrative of the left it's
been the narrative of the media
so why exactly would we trust the media
when it comes to either shutting down or
reopening because
here is now the editorial board of the
washington post coming along in december
right in the middle of the worst
outbreak that we've seen thus far
an editorial board that was like ah you
know we're not sure about this whole
school thing we're not you know
here is the editorial board of the
washington post what could have changed
in the last month could there be an
election or something
because here's the new headline students
have already lost too much time they
need to be back in classrooms
oh weird because those of us were saying
this months ago were castigated and are
still being castigated by the teachers
unions as people who don't care about
the lives of teachers who are bad
uncaring unfeeling evil now here's the
washington post
that was propagating a lot of this panic
porn for months on end and they're like
you know what it's time for kids to go
back to school yeah no bleep sherlock
but you think i'm gonna trust you on
that rongo
not going to trust you on that i'm going
to trust people who've been fairly
consistent throughout this whole thing
looking for reasonable measures but here
comes the washington post
and why look at that they think joe
biden was elected president and now
they've reversed themselves on schooling
since the outbreak of the coven 19
pandemic teachers principals
administrators and parents
across the us have worked mightily to
help students keep learning
students developed new curricula provide
schools developed new curricula
provided children with portable
computers labor to give some semblance
of structure to remote learning
even with these efforts remote learning
has failed to provide anything
approaching the quality of education
that can be delivered by a teacher
in a classroom it's clear that there are
pernicious effects of keeping children
out of schools we recently asked a top
official in a washington area
jurisdiction who insisted on anonymity
why there wasn't more of a push to
figure out ways to return children to
the classroom
the answer was there was no political
pressure parents of means can give their
kids the help and resources they need or
switch them to a private school
parents of minority or disadvantaged
students with the most to lose have the
least clouds
well maybe it's because you in the media
didn't do your damn jobs on the covid
pandemic all the way from the beginning
and you're still not doing your job
you're still not doing your job okay you
continue to purvey
the panic porn that suggests that
everybody is equally likely to die of
this virus
you keep suggesting over and over that
full-scale lockdowns that are completely
hypocritical in their actual application
are totally fine
when's the last time by the way you saw
a business owner who'd been completely
destroyed on cnn or msnbc you only see
it on fox news you only hear about that
from my show or shows like it you won't
hear it in the media but this is the
media that asks you to trust them
this is the same media that's blaming
trump for a lack of covered relief well
now nancy pelosi is completely flipped
on covert relief and nobody in the media
will even notice it so nancy pelosi who
has held up a covert relief package for
months on end for no apparent political
reason other than to get beyond the
election
because she thought it would hurt trump
now she says we're not leaving
washington dc without the relief
and the media are like oh look at that
nancy pelosi leader it's incredible
here's nancy pelosi being a giant
hypocrite we have to have an omnibus
and we're hoping that that will
accelerate the discussions on the
omnibus
we are going to keep government open you
know we're not going to have a
continuing resolution
but we need to take the time to do that
and then as i said we saw a framework
they're putting uh now they have to turn
it into
text and then and so we'll take the time
we need
and we must get it done and we must get
it done by uh this
before we leave we cannot leave without
it
i mean and the media just went right
along with this the meteor just like oh
look at that nancy pelosi leader
yeah i trust you guys i trust you guys
on covet i trust you guys uncovered
relief i trust you guys on voter fraud
or i don't trust you on any of this
stuff it is it is your lack of
credibility that has led to a rise of
radical almost deconstructionist
skepticism
in the very notion that there is such a
thing as a fact or truth
you know there are a lot of people in
the media who said we live in a
post-truth era yeah you created it
you created the post-truth era if you
want uh
revision of that era if you want to go
back to the truth
how about this how about you be the
skeptics and i mean that you need to
actually check your own side
ask tough questions of nancy pelosi or
joe biden and maybe
maybe at that point somebody will start
from the right thinking they are a
credible source otherwise
shut up nobody trusts you i mean you're
ridiculous you're just ridiculous
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content